une mutuelle de village pour faciliter
l'accès aux soins à voisins le
bretonneux c'est la mesure phare
annoncée par la maire de la commune avec
son art aux eti pendant ses voeux
vendredi dernier objectif de ce
dispositif permet trop bissy noyau
personnes travaillant à voisin d'être
couverts à des tarifs préférentiels
négocié par la ville c'est souvent là la
première économique les gens font sur
leurs dépenses
il supprime la mutuelle et on sait bien
que les problèmes de santé qu'on peut
avoir avoir une mutuelle c'est vraiment
capital
donc on s'est dit que on se regroupant
comme l'ont fait d'autres villes être
plus fort il y avoir des bons tarifs
pour développer ce projet un
questionnaire a été lancée dans la ville
pour identifier les besoins des
habitants
les frais d'hospitalisation d'optique et
soins dentaires ont été plébiscités par
les vies si noir ce qui nous intéresse
mon épouse et moi c'est le prix je
trouve que l'initiative de la mairie est
une bonne chose
cette mutuelle de couverture santé ses
skis et prend dix ont dit des cours
croyez vous important est de plus en
plus important chaque année et donc je
crois que c'est quelque chose qui
préoccupe beaucoup les retraités ce qui
est mon cas ce dossier m'intéresse
énormément à l'issue d'un appel d'offres
la mutuelle prévoyance des salariés mps
a été retenu par la municipalité
la cotisation mensuelle individuel
démarre à 58 euros 50 par mois pour les
50 ans et plus le tarif est à 25 euros
40 pour les moins de 30 ans disons que
la comparaison qui a été fait par
voisins-le-bretonneux
ils ont trouvé nos cotisations adapté
par rapport aux prestations
contrairement aux uns des autres à
d'autres propositions qui leur étaient
faites pour plus d'informations la
mutuelle proposés permanence le prochain
rendez vous est fixé le 27 janvier
prochain à la maison des associations